this was a barbed wire bottle rug yeah
that was markiplier level okay why thank
you for the markiplier level your
awesome surprise Thank You al mark
you're the best
oh well okay bye
I'm just gonna go along and not think
about what the hell just escaped from
the body of my dead child and then fly
like a butterfly sting like Oh what I
couldn't tell everything is chaos right
now okay okay okay Thank You Tyler four
five seven one for that one thank you
space sheep markiplier adventure I can
do this can i man some of you guys make
it the most creative oh oh wait about it
it was a troll transcribe shut up stop
complaining you get the cookie okay yeah
the severed hands about Kenny's here but
at least I got a cookie her Thank You MC
CooCoo no no you're all cool no I just
gotta break this other one can't get
enough momentum because it's stupid ones
here there we go No thank you no or
margwa aerospike Polly 85% impossible
thank you so much mark black creator
also known as Curtis you say it's pretty
challenging but okay I'm totally
possible
I'm done this gotta be very okay that's
not possible
well you absorb all those attacks Janice
it's gonna go on his merry way
pull oh why thank you market black
creator again for making this one fun
ones there's another markiplier fall
where are we fine alright could he just
want to take the blows for me not blow
for me funny oh oh
usually Santa sleigh get out of these
situations pot boy ok you don't need to
rush it oh ok that's a possible but
thank you man t2 okay I got one
accelerating me through my crotch
okay so dead accelerated me in this
bikes why do they keep attaching to my
crotch that's what I want to know
okay so I'm not even a little bit okay
let go my son let go let go let go sign
let go okay I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
make it oh god why did I go that way oh
damn it what do you guys choose to make
these so impossible thank you
markiplier hard by unicorn Oh 723 I
don't know if that's just a comment
about me or about the level I think that
landmine is just the bad joke filter so
I just got to stop making them oh okay
it just wants to go me okay oh you
didn't hurt okay that hurt me a lot I'm
just markable our course by X did shot
XO 600 somehow so I'm but not on my bike
just gotta make it through that be
beaten okay so okay so okay Oh missed it
so badly okay Oh Oh ninja master
hyperspace hold up to slice uh-oh oh my
god what's wrong with my sword whoa oh
my god okay why do they keep running
after me no no no do it no I don't want
to do this I didn't water I saved you
from a fate worse than death
okay bye there goes your nards and there
goes you hello no girl you want some
candy
all I have is death hello little boy
your sisters over there
right over there go by where what's
going on over this is kind of horror why
did they explode they were dead enough I
guess you can never be dead enough
[Laughter]
you're not dead you're standing right
there
poon run whoa no nope okay maybe I'm
dead
bike why oh oh well okay then no oh I'm
kind of not really at all huh here come
to not get me cuz I'm full of vim and
vigor oh that hurt mob up think you got
my kid they're doing good we're good god
damn how long is this oh I think maybe I
won yeah oh if you break your arms press
okay bye son just gonna go on my way oh
yeah helmet the helmet did not help me
oh why why oh why why more try monk okay
50% hard like 50 percent not wrong
that was the one half well then we lost
one Rudolf took a beating to the face
this nose was a little red more than red
okay my joke was bad
camel walk kitties we need to get you to
school so that Mommy could go to the bar
get you to school so that Mommy could go
to group therapy oh god mommy loves you
very much and oh that's up my butt but
oddly I go to mind in my mind that I
mind that a lot swore throw assassin are
you vomiting I got just the medicine
right up your butt for maximum effect if
'ti wealth didn't mean to kill you meant
hit the watermelon you kind of just
killed yourself there sorry about that
um and there's another one for your butt
congratulations you got a twofer and you
got one in your back and Santa's got one
in his face and you I didn't feel like
killing you
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video